a mysterious new army has struck Babylon
without warning
spreading terror throughout the city
with ruthless efficiency these dark
warriors of Catoosa would go on to
destroy anything in their way
their mission to become the greatest
empire the world had ever seen
yet once they had succeeded this
ruthless army and the vast empire they
created simply disappeared as
mysteriously as they had emerged for
3,000 years all trace of them was lost
from all the history books and even from
myth and legend till one by one
fragments from this lost world began to
emerge these fragments opened up a world
of mysteries and secret codes a fortress
city built to last forever an
unstoppable war machine
and a mighty empire even greater than
that of Egypt this is the story of how a
civilization built to last forever could
simply vanish from history